kanye west huh kanye west you could have
failed to see his genius first first of
all the way the way i even met and i did
i blew it
i didn't blow it but it worked out
i know it's not making sense because i
haven't told you the story yet but what
happened was that i'm throwing a party
for i throw all these parties in my crib
so i'm throwing a party for puff and
jay-z's there and pharrell's a big party
and this kid walks in with with a
backpack on and his jaw is busted and i
said who's that and they said that's
kanye west i said what do you do they
say he raps and you know he he produces
for jay-z that's what everybody comes to
my house got to perform i got i got i
got to see what this dude had so i
walked into him and i said yo man they
say you do your thing you know you rat
and he killed with this freestyle was
amazing i said wow
well you're going to be famous right
and then he said to me he said he said
uh i have a
a song that that i think that you would
be great on uh if we could go uh to the
studio
uh that song i said man what i'm trying
to get in the music business let's go
cause i wasn't in the music business and
i happen to have a studio in my crib so
we go in the back
we heard that yeah but the reason i did
that because i would throw parties for
musical people so i could try to get on
a record so
that's why paul and jay-z and all them
were there they didn't know but
we go in the studio and he says the song
uh goes uh she says she wants some
marvin gaye some luther van gaal i said
i got it i got it i gotta she said she
wants some marvin good and so he said yo
what are you doing
i said well you know you don't know you
don't know r b see i'm r b singer so i
got to put the r b thing on us i got to
do that he said uh don't do that
just seeing it simple because it's you
know it's hip-hop and i was like all
right so i sung it begrudgingly thinking
this song is wack he's not going to make
it it's not going to work right so i
left and i went and did a bad movie and
i came back
put your jacket
[Music]
[Laughter]
i do this bad movie i come back and i'm
in miami and my boy was like yo remember
that song you said was wack it's number
one in the country wow and so that's how
uh that's how you get it wrong but right
sometimes yeah that's yeah whoo well
look at you
uh michael jackson was a real hero of
yours um and yeah so now you
you did you meet him or you didn't meet
him there was a no no i never i no i
talked to him on the phone yes how did
that happen
uh i would how did it happen i was
i was in paris and i was with uh kenny
ortega we were promoting high school
musical three i want to say it was it
was probably 20
maybe 20 or 21 at the time
and we were at dinner and um
somehow i got at that was at the head of
the table and kenny was on the other
side of the table our director kenny
ortega and um his phone rang and i
remember i got this look like
you want this phone i was like okay so i
came over and i was like what's going on
he goes it's michael jackson i'm like
what he asked me the phone and i was
like uh hello
and i heard um
hi who's this
i was like
um
this is zac efron i'm a massive fan and
i'm an actor and you're like my hero and
i
didn't know what to say i was like kind
of i was just at a loss for words and uh
rambling on and then he said
that's really nice can you hand the
phone back to kenny
that's what i did and i i was freaking
out like i just talked to michael
jackson he's my hero i was just tripping
um
and i sat back down just a little dizzy
and then all of a sudden the phone rang
again and um
kenny answered and i saw him kind of
confused across the table and and uh
he like looked at me again he's like
you want to get to the phone and i was
like okay and he hands the phone to me
goes it's michael jackson again
and i was like
what okay and i picked up the phone i
was like hello and he goes oh this is
zach from high school musical and i was
like
uh yeah and he was like oh i'm i love
what you do i'm a huge fan
i know what you do
and
i've lost it i just
i lost my balance i think i fell over
into the wall i started i was like do
you know who i am
and i just started crying i was a mess
like literally i was just making a fool
out of myself i like slid down to the
floor pathetically and professed how
much i loved him said like you're my
hero you're the reason i do what i do
like thank you so much michael for
everything and
uh thanks for showing me how to dance
how to be you know how to how to believe
in myself how to
how to
i don't know how to shine you know and
um
that made him cry
they were both crying to each other on
the phone and he ended the whole phone
call conversation with um
something along the lines of
hey zach and i like stopped crying for a
second he's like isn't it isn't it
awesome and i was like what and he goes
dreams really do come true don't they
when i was like
oh come on i was like you can't say
things like that
you're killing me man
how are you it's good thank you nice to
meet you too yeah yeah again yeah i get
it because i went to see michael in
concert the other day yeah
it was so good i saw your film as well
it was very good
it was nice too because i could see you
there was a point where i was singing
and i looked back and all i saw you you
had i think a glass of wine
yeah
and i saw it very clearly and the other
you were doing this
and you were dancing i thought yes he's
into it he's into it i was i loved it i
loved it now uh you you've worked with
jennifer haven't you yes
i was on her special yeah and we've we
we've met up at different functions and
things yeah and have you met dame judy
jens before no we have now hi yes
it's nice to meet you
and
now i don't know does matthew know that
he plays a special part in your life
uh no probably not please i play a
special part in your life yeah
can't wait to hear this well i mean
i my wife and i sleep with you almost
every night yes yes
and every night there's an app called
calm
and i have insomnia and he has the most
beautiful voice and i turn it on
and i just hear where hello everybody
it's me matthew mcconaughey i'm going to
tell you a bedtime story and i just do
this oh
honestly got truth about it is my wife
who's from argentina she always goes
like you have the man talking again
the man is talking in the bed again
it's great though i love this it cost me
80 bucks
well it was well worth it have you gone
no we've got a little bit because i just
thought it was you reading stories but
you are actually putting people to bed
this is this is matthew mcconaughey on
the app
but tonight
i hope to send you off to peaceful
dreams with that very thing in mind
let your eyes close and your breath fall
soft and slow
as we begin our story
which just might rekindle
that sense of wonder
[Applause]
you've noticed something about british
people and the way
they speak that we do a funny thing well
well no i mean i love all the every
regional accent every time
uh i'm a big fan you're not getting into
that scone mess
um uh but i i like that because there's
so many accents to such a small country
everybody sort of puts on different
voices when they're doing little bits
but i had a thing where uh i was
checking into a hotel
and somebody came out and said oh do you
need help with your bags and i i thought
they were doing a bit
so um i went oh i've been traveling all
day i have no idea
and then they
um kept talking like that
so i had to like slowly transition out
of it and i know that that sounds like
an exaggeration of their voice but then
i was back in the country several years
later and they were on tv on gogglebox
because it was steph and dom from
so they actually talk like that that is
i never knew that that was a real hotel
that represented yeah but you stayed
there stayed there and accidentally made
fun of them to their face
allen what's that story you have about
that is it yeah a very good friend of
mine she was going for a really
stressful time and and a lovely aunt
said listen i'm going to get you a head
massage so she went to this clinic had a
head massage she was in the room and the
woman said uh can you take your knickers
off
bit weird for a head massage okay
okay yeah so she took her knickers off
and she's like that
and then the woman came back in she was
south african she went no nicholas
nicholas
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this is so sweet i don't i haven't seen
this picture before this is uh you in
school and you've sort of changed a lot
and not changed at all this is you just
in there
what were you what were you giving well
that was a play called fried bacon and
fried bungies elizabethan play written
about shakespeare's time and i was
playing the young heroine oh but but
there were girls in school
you can't quite see the boy in the sixth
form who i was madly in love with do you
want to try and find him brian he's
quite handsome that one no no never mind
i don't know him
i'm going to struggle
i mean it's a good game but uh i'm not
sure
i'm not sure i'll get it yeah
he might be just out of shot i think yes
oh dear and people obviously get very
excited when you go on tour and places
rather
you've got a blue plaque haven't you
most people have to die to get a blue
plaque
i've got a number of bloopers oh have
you ever i've got one on the house where
i was born in burnley but i i did go and
visit it on my second only visit to
burnley because we left when i was two
months old and i think they put it on
the wrong house
no this other one is in liverpool i
think or leeds maybe i think it's liv we
thought it was leeds but i think it's
like we think it's liverpool
yes yes well what was that doing there i
think i can tell you what you were doing
there i could tell you what you're doing
there
siri miguel and sat here on table five
and enjoyed a jacket potato in a latte
[Applause]
that's precisely what you were doing
there
yeah yeah
where do you know where that is
it's it's on the university campus oh
yes was it a nice potato
liverpool's looking gorgeous these days
since they've done it up oh yeah
[Music]
i mean i used to go to liverpool when i
was a kid and it was a dangerous and
dirty and dank place pre-beetles
everything but now of course it's it's
spanking it's terrific oh it's beautiful
now yes and uh in the show obviously
you'll be you know as you said you'll be
talking about shakespeare and doing
scenes
but you'll be uh also telling stories
about your your life and
people you've worked with there's a
story actually do you damn you just try
don't ask me just tell another maggie
smith story no
every time i see her she said you've not
been doing me again
now you've done her again
it is traditional at this point in the
show when john bishop is on the couch to
turn to the americans to say
understanding anything yeah
no no i'm getting it wrong
oh yeah yeah
[Laughter]
this is a weird thing so chris pratt is
this this seems so unlikely that you
have now learned how to do the voices
from towie yeah sort of yeah
we love that garbage tv back in
my wife was crazy about it and when i
was
here filming guardians we shot guardians
of the galaxy here in in london and
and my wife anna came out to visit
and she fell in love with this show
towie the only way is essex it's this
show that's like basically their jersey
shorts the jersey shore from right from
here it's like this uh
town somewhere essex i guess and
these folks are just like the worst and
it was like i'm a parrot a little bit
and so when i hear when i hear it all
the time i just started picking it up
and started like i could pick up their
accent and do their accent a little bit
you know yeah i'm okay it's gonna sound
this is really embarrassing to do in
front of a whole room full of brits here
but i'll try it anyways so it's like
so like honestly i like i saw this guy
[Applause]
because he's telling me he's like you
know no i miss you or whatever and i'm
like
you miss me what am i your mother
[Applause]
that will never be useful that would be
useful but that's very good now i want
to watch
i love the fact that you spent months in
england and that's what you talk about
i have read will that you have
this amazing amount of music that you
haven't released but tracks with
extraordinary artists like michael
jackson and prince and people like that
will you ever release those tracks uh no
because you know especially artists like
michael jackson where working with
michael jackson is his critique and his
two cents
so you know without him guiding on
completing it it's not my right to
to do that he was a friend so i wouldn't
i wouldn't do that and what was the
story that you brought michael jackson
and princeton yes
you
you brought michael jackson and prince
together yeah so one time we had a show
in um in vegas and
michael jackson called
hey where's michael okay
yeah so i heard you guys are doing the
show tonight yeah we're going at nine
o'clock
oh rats i gotta put the kids to sleep
so i was like well i'm performing with
prince later on
at 12. so anyways michael came to see me
rock with prince
and it was a it was a magnificent night
to see it was me chris tucker and then
watching me chris tucker michael jackson
watching prince rock on stage
so
to make a long story short prince steps
off the stage and plays the bass in
michael jackson's face
rips the freaking base in
10 different pieces
make a longer story shorter michael
jackson leaves and goes home and says
leave me in the house for breakfast so i
go to his house with breakfast knock on
the door
first words he says
why was prince playing the base of my
face
though cause he's no no prince
he's just being nice you know no prince
he's always been a meanie
but bless their hearts they were so
passionate and um
you know we've lost a great musician
[Music]